NO SWEAT SO LET'S DO THIS-
SINCE SINCE WE NOW HAVE A
QUORUM LET LET'S GO AHEAD AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND THEN
WE'LL START HERE JUST ANOTHER
MINUTE OR SO MISTER SECRETARY
IF YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL THE
STATE WAS QUORUM. NUMBER HERE
NUMBER HERE NIELSEN. NIELSEN
HERE HERTZBERG YEAH HERTZBERG
HERE LEYVA LEYVA HERE STERN. WE
HAVE A CORE. WILL BEGIN HERE
MOMENTARILY. YEAH. YES SERVICE.
RIGHT YEAH. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS WILL
COME TO ORDER LET ME BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
THIS IS A DIFFICULT TIME FOR
NUMBER REASONS AND I KNOW
SEVERAL OF YOU HAVE HAD TO-
TRAVEL THAT AT SOME PERSONAL
RISK TO BE HERE TODAY SO I'M
MOST GRATEFUL FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. LET ME ALSO SAY THAT
RESPONSE A COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC SENATORS AND SENATE
STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING AND IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENT TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC. CONTINUE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO LET THE PROCESS
WHILE CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN
A WAY THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC IN OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALL THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER I'M GONNA GIVE
THAT EVERYONE JUST A MOMENT TO
SPEND TOLL FREE NUMBER. AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WILL ALSO BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT HERE IN A
MOMENT. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR IN
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN EIGHT
THREE SIX SEVEN FOUR FIVE WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE IS
THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE. THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR YOU. AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED THE
REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
CONDUCTED HEARINGS AS CLOSE TO
THE SAME AREA MANNERS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAP
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE USE. OR NEW
ONLINE TOOLS DIGESTING TO THE
USE OF NEW ONLINE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
BUT TODAY WE ONLY HAVE ONE BILL
IN TODAY'S AGENDA THAT'S AB
EIGHT SIXTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MARC BERMAN THE ESTEEM CHAIROF
THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS AND-
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE AS YOU CAN
SEE I'M ALSO COR THIRD QUARTER
THIS MEASURE- BEFORE WE HERE
MISTER BERMAN'S PRESENTATION
THE BILL LET'S ESTABLISH KERR
WE ALREADY DONE THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. CORN IS
BEEN A STABLE AND NOW LET'S
HEAR FROM THE AUTHOR ON AB
EIGHT SIXTY SEVEN MEMBER BERMAN
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU NUMBER IN COLLEAGUES
AND REALLY APPRECIATE EVERYBODY
COMING TOGETHER- JUST THIS ONE
BILL AND THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE. NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO
RISK THEIR HEALTH AND POSSIBLY
THEIR LIFE. TO EXERCISE THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO VOTE. I
HOPE WE CAN ALL AGREE WITH THAT
STATEMENT. YEAH THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE SAW ON APRIL SEVENTH OF
THIS YEAR WHEN WISCONSINITES
WERE FORCED TO VOTE IN PERSON
IN THEIR PRIMARY ELECTION AND-
STAY FOR HOURS IN LINES THAT
STRETCH FOR MILES. IN THE
MIDDLE OF A DEADLY HEALTH
PANDEMICS AMERICAN CITIZENS
YOUNG AND OLD. WERE DENIED THE
ABILITY TO VOTE BY MAIL AND
WERE FORCED TO LEAVE THE SAFETY
OF THEIR HOMES TO VOTE IN
PERSON. DESPITE THE BEST
EFFORTS OF ELECTIONS OFFICIALS.
THOUSANDS OF VOTERS TO REQUEST
AN ABSENTEE BALLOTS DID NOT
RECEIVE THEM IN TIME TO VOTE
AND RETURN THEM BY ELECTION DAY.
THEY WERE EFFECTIVELY
DISENFRANCHISED IN THE
AFTERMATH OF WISCONSIN'S
ELECTION IS BECOME CLEAR THAT
THE HEALTH CONCERNS OF FORCING
PEOPLE INTO IN PERSON VOTING
DURING A PANDEMIC ARE ALL TOO
REAL AN ANALYSIS BY THE
WISCONSIN DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES FOUND THAT AT LEAST
SEVENTY ONE PEOPLE TRACK TO THE
COVER NINETEEN VIRUS AFTER
VOTING IN PERSON OR WORKING AT
THE POLLS AT THE APRIL ELECTION.
SO ONCE AGAIN. VOTER SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO RISK THEIR HEALTH. AND
POSSIBLY THEIR LIFE IN ORDER TO
EXERCISE THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO VOTE. THIS IS ONE OF
INTRODUCED AB EIGHT SIXTY WOULD
REQUIRE THAT EVERY REGISTERED
CALIFORNIA VOTER EMAIL THE
BALLOT FOR THIS NOVEMBER'S
GENERAL ELECTION. THIS WILL
ENSURE THAT EVERY THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIA VOTER HAS THE
ABILITY TO VOTE FROM THE SAFETY
OF THEIR OWN HOME.
UNFORTUNATELY OPPONENTS OF THIS
BILL HAVE ARGUED THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING TO MAIL BALLOTS TO
INACTIVE VOTE THIS THIS
OBVIOUSLY IS NOT TRUE.
ELECTIONS CODE SECTION TWO TWO
pINACTIVE VOTERS DO NOT RECEIVE
ELECTION MATERIALS WHICH
INCLUDES BALLOTS. FURTHERMORE
THE LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL IS
MODELED AFTER LANGUAGE IN
EXISTING LAW THAT GOVERNS
ELECTIONS CONDUCTED UNDER THE
VOTERS CHOICE ACT MAIL BALLOT
ELECTIONS AND ALL MAIL BALLOT
PRECINCTS. NONE OF THOSE LAWS
HAVE BEEN INTERPRETED TO
REQUIRE MAILING BALLOTS TO AN
ACTIVE VOTERS. TO EVEN THOUGH I
FEEL A LITTLE BIT SILLY HAVING
TO EMPHASIZE THAT THIS BILL
CLEARLY REQUIRES BALLOTS TO BE
MAILED ONLY TO ACTIVE
REGISTERED VOTERS I WANT TO
MAKE THAT MEAN ESPECIALLY CLEAR
ON THE RECORD TO HELP DISPEL
THE RUMORS THAT ARE BEING
PERPETRATED. PERPETUATED BY
GROUPS AND INDIVIDUALS WHO SEEK
TO UNDERMINE CALIFORNIANS FAITH
IN THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTIONS. I ALSO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT EIGHTY EIGHT
SIXTY WOULD NOT ELIMINATE IN IN
VOTING UP. TELL WILL NEED SAFE
IN SOME VOTING. THIS NOVEMBER
BECAUSE BECAUSE THEY NEVER
RECEIVED A BALLOT. THE LOSS OR
DAMAGE THE BALLOT THEY NEED
LANGUAGE OR VOTING ASSISTANCE
OR THEY NEED TO REGISTER TO
VOTE. TO OWN IT THANK YOU-
CHAIR ON BERG FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP. IN OFFERING SB FOUR
TWENTY THREE THE BILL THAT I AM
PROUD TO JOINTLY AUTHOR. TO
ENSURE THAT SAFE AND HEALTHY IN
PERSON VOTING OPTIONS ARE
AVAILABLE SO THAT ALL VOTERS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO VOTE
PRIVATELY. AND INDEPENDENTLY.
FINALLY AB EIGHT SIXTY MAKES A
NUMBER OF OTHER IMPORTANT
ACCOMMODATIONS TO HELP
FACILITATE THE EXPECTED SURGE
IN VOTING BY MAIL. AT THIS
NOVEMBER'S ELECTION. IT ALLOWS
COUNTIES TO BEGIN PROCESSING
RETURN VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS
EARLIER. SO THAT THEY CAN
BETTER MANAGE THEIR WORKLOADS
AND GET MORE BALLOTS COUNT ON
ELECTION NIGHT. IT EXTENDS THE
DEADLINE FOR SEE THE VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOTS TODAY VOTERS ARE
NOT DISENFRANCHISED BY ANY
POTENTIAL POSTAL SERVICE DELAYS.
IT ALLOWS ALL VOTERS TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE FLEXIBILITY
OFFERED BY REMOTE ACCESSIBLE
VOTE BY MAIL SYSTEMS WHICH CAN
BE ESPECIALLY HELPFUL FOR
VOTERS WHO NEED REPLACEMENT
BALLOTS OR WHO WANT TO RECEIVE
A BALLOT IN THEIR PREFERRED
LANGUAGE. FINALLY AB EIGHT
SIXTY WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO TRACK THEIR BALLOTS.
AS THEY MOVE THROUGH THE MAIL
SYSTEM AND ARE PROCESSED BY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS. THAT WOULD
BE REMISS. POINT THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP IN A LETTER OF
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. IT'S
OPPOSITION LETTER. THE ELECTION
INTO THE ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT STATES AND I QUOTE IT
IS UNDERSTANDABLE TO LOOK TO
THE VOTE BY MAIL PROCESS TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF VOTERS TO
PARTICIPATE. IN AN ELECTION
WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING THEIR
THEIR HEALTH OR SAFETY AND THE
TIME A PANDEMIC THREAT. BUT TO
MAINTAIN ELECTORAL INTEGRITY
THERE MUST BE EXTRA EFFORT
EXPENDED TOWARD SHORE THAT VOTE
JEWISH TO ASSURE THE VOTERS.
THAT THE QUEUE WERE IS NOT MORE
LETHAL THAN THE DISEASE. I FIND
THAT ARGUMENT TO BE INCREDIBLY
EXPENSIVE AND IN POOR TASTE.
VOTING BY MAIL HAS NEVER
BECAUSE ANYONE'S
HOSPITALIZATION OR DEATH. BUT
GIVEN THE COVERT INETEEN
HEALTH PANDEMIC IN UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THERE WILL
BE A SURGEON CASES RIGHT BEFORE
THE GENERAL ELECTION. THERE'S A
VERY REAL CHANCE THAT A LACK OF
THAT A LACK OF ACCESS. TO
VOTING BY MAIL OR BY FORCING
VOTERS INTO CROWDED POLLING
BOOTH. WARS OR WILL RESULT IN
BOTH HOSPITALIZATION AND-
5 DEGREES WITH. POLICY MEDICINE
PASS I THINK THAT ARGUMENT IS
BEYOND THE PALE. AB EIGHT SIXTY
SUPPORT BY A LONG LIST OF
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTING
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AT THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
AND THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AS WELL AS
BY SECRETARY OF STATE. ALEX
PADILLA THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
SENATORS FOR CONSIDERATION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND TESTIFYING TODAY IS
ROBBIE AVALON OFF FROM THE
OFFICE OF SECRETARY OF STATE
ALEX BUT THE- THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN- FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
FORWARD THIS IS A INCREDIBLY
CRITICAL ELECTION. AND THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIA'S VOTERS IS COURSE
PARAMOUNT SO APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. BOB
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
NEW CLEANING PROTOCOLS
COMMITTEES WILL INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY THAT'S ROCK
COMMITTEES. CURRENTLY EACH SIDE
WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED TOTAL OF
THREE MINUTES THAT'S FOR THE-
FOLKS WHO ARE THE PRIMARY
POLICY AND PROPONENTS. FIVE
MUST MEET THE COMMON SUIT THEIR
NAME. THEIR AFFILIATION AND
THEIR POSITION IN THE SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE OR IF YOU ARE IN
BETWEEN I SUPPOSE YOU CAN CALL
YOURSELF A TWEENER. BOB I
UNDERSTAND SOMEONE FROM THE
SECTOR STATES OFFICES
ASSEMBLYMAN. BERMAN'S PRIMARY
WITNESS- ROBERT I'M ALONG WITH
THE SECTORS STATES OFFICE- IF
YOU'RE ON THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE AND READY TO PROCEED ON
THE CALL UPON YOU. MR ALONG ARE
YOU PREPARED. YES I AM ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD GO AHEAD ALLOW THE
STRUGGLING TO TESTIFY. GO AHEAD
THE LINE IN THE WINTER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
AND I THINK YOU CAN REMEMBER
BERMAN AND YOUR STAFF NEAR
SOUTH READERSHIP ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. I'M ROBERT
AVALON ON BEHALF OF SECRETARY
OF STATE ALEX YEAH AND HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AB EIGHT
SIXTY ONE SURE EVERY VOTER IS
ABLE TO CAST A BALLOT DURING-
THE PANDEMIC IN A SAFE MANNER.
THIS BILL DOES NOT ELIMINATE IN
PERSON VOTING AT OPTION WILL
STILL BE AVAILABLE AND NOVEMBER.
FOR THE UPCOMING ELECTION.
ROUGHLY 87% OF THAT TWENTY
POINT SIX SIX MILLION
REGISTERED VOTERS. WILL ALREADY
BE RECEIVING A BALLOT IN THE
MAIL. AB EIGHT SIXTY PROVIDES
THAT THE REMAINING VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA THE BILL BY MAIL
BALLOT. ALLOW MORE CALIFORNIA
VOTERS TO HAVE THE OPTION TO
BOTH SAFELY IN THEIR HOMES SO
THAT VOTERS DO NOT HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN THE RIGHT TO
VOTE. THE HEALTH. ALLOWS THEM
TO DO BOTH. ANOTHER ASPECT OF
THE BILL ALLOW COUNTY STOP FOR
THE BALLOT TRACKING FOR VOTERS
WHICH ARE AGENCY CURRENTLY
OFFERS THE COUNTY. NO COST THE
COUNTIES TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
BALLOT TRACK SYSTEM IN WHICH A
MAJORITY OF COUNTY IS ALREADY
PARTICIPATING. AS WELL OUT OF
ORDERS TO HAVE AN OPTION TO SEE
THE LOCATION OF THE BALLOT IN
THE MAILING PROCESS SIMILAR TO
HOW. YOU CAN TRACK A PACKAGE IN
THE MAIL. ANOTHER ASPECT OF THE
BILL WILL ALLOW COUNTIES TO
OFFER. REMOTE ACCESSIBLE THE
BILL BY MAIL TO AVAILABLE. TO
MAKE AVAILABLE TO ALL THE
OTHERS. WHAT IS CURRENTLY AN
OPTION FOR OVERSEAS VOTERS
MILITARY VOTERS. AND THERE'S A
DISABILITIES. HI I WANT TO
THANK AS A MEMBER BERMAN FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
AND THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE
FORCE COOPER SHIP. SO I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF SECRETARY OF STATE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER ALONG. BOB SO. ARE THERE
ANY OTHERS THAT OUR PRIMARY
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL- IN
SUPPORT ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN A
SHOULD WE TURN TO OTHER
WITNESSES. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA FIRST GO TO OF ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE RIGHT HERE I
DON'T SEE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HERE DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
HERE. NOW ALL RIGHT HOW ABOUT
ROOM TWENTY FORTY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY TWENTY FORTY LOOKS LIKE
IT IS EMPTY ALL RIGHT. SO NOW
WE'RE NOT GOING TO IN A MOMENT
WE'RE GONNA TURN TO TURN TO THE
PHONE LINES- WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO IS FOLKS ON THE PHONE CAN
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES AND SHOULD
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES. THEIR
POSITION IN THEIR ORGANIZATION
IF THEY HAVE ONE- ALL RIGHT IS
ABOUT A MODERATOR IT. IF WE NOW
COULD TURN TO THE PHONE LINES.
THEN FR THOSE IN SUPPORT WE'RE
TAKING THOSE IN SUPPORT. MADAME
MODERATOR ARE YOU WITH US.
WOMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
SIXTY COULD FOR. ALL MADAM
OPERATOR A WE COULDN'THEAR THE
LAST PART OF WHAT YOU HAD TO
SAY. ONE ZERO ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO. MODERATOR YOU
HEAR ME. IF YOU CAN HEAR MY
VOICE I THINK YOU NEED TO GO
AHEAD AND MAKE YOUR
ANNOUNCEMENT ONE MORE TIME SO
IT'S COMPLETELY HEARD. TURNING.
THE GERMAN. MADAM OPERATOR FOR
WHATEVER REASON YOU ARE CUTTING
IN AND OUT ARE YOU NOT ABLE TO
HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW
YES OKAY ONE. THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX. PRESS. ONE
ZERO. OKAY MY MOM IS. TURNING
AND YOUR CUTTING ALL MY AND ONE
MOMENT. AND THEN I GOT WIDER
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA PULL
WE'RE GONNA PAUSE FOR JUST A
MOMENT TO GET OUR TECHNOLOGIES
ONE MOMENT DETERMINE. ONE
MOMENT THERE. OKAY MY CAN YOU
HEAR ME NOW. I CAN HEAR YOU
MADAME MODERATOR. BUT WE
SQUARED AWAY. HELLO MISTER
CHAIRMAN CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW.
BY ES IS EVER ON THE PHONE I
CAN HEAR NOW OKAY THANK. YES
THIS COMPLICATED WE WILL GO TO
THE LINE OF ONE THIRTY TO ONE
THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU. OKAY MOVING ON THE
LINE. OKAY GREAT LINE ONE
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD MORNING THE CENTER I'M
BURKE AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN- MY NAME IS MABEL THING
AND I AM CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BOND ON THE
PLAN- ANIMALS UP FIND URBAN
SUBURBAN GROWN ON CORPORATE
CARE TOWARDS THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATING IMPACTED BY COLD IN
NINETEEN WE PRINT THE NUMBER
BONDING AND ON BEHALF OF WHAT I
WANT TO HOLD THE FOR A BI.
BATMAN BRIDGE TEN GRAND IN
RESPONSE BY MAIL OKAY KNOW
GOING PANAMA SO WHAT ALSO I
HAVE WHAT WE NEED DO. WE ALSO
ASK FOR FULL FUNDING AND WISH.
OF BOTH PACKAGE OF ALL RIGHT
SOME MODERATOR HERE HERE'S A WE
NEED TO DO FOR THE- I DON'T IF
YOU CAN HEAR ME VOICE BUT FOR
THOSE. ARE TO. VIA TELECOM. OF
THEY NEED TO. GO AHEAD AND
THEIR NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION
AND THEIR POSITION THE THOSE
THREE ELEMENTS ARE IT. SO IN IT
WE ARE CONSTRAINED BY A NUMBER
OF. FACTORS ONE OF WHICH IS
TIME SO. OF A IF WE COULD TO
THE NEXT SPEAKER BUT IF WE GO
BEYOND. THOSE THREE ELEMENTS
SOMEONE ASKED THAT WE CONTINUE
TO MOVE ON SO ALL RIGHT. META
MODERATOR WE CAN GO THE NEXT. A
SUPPORTER YEAH YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THAT LINE UP TO
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
HERE A NUMBER OF MOMENTS THAT
WERE MARROW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN ORDER EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE TWO
OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
HERE IN MEMBERS ERIN RODRIGUEZ
COULD UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS WITH STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE TWO
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
HELLO THAN WHAT THE WIDENING
GROUP REPRESENTING NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE COURT. THANK
YOU. LINE TWO FIFTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS SHANNON HOLDEN AND THE
DIRECTOR OF NARAL BECAUSE
CALIFORNIANS DON'T SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE TO
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MORNING CENTER BREYER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING YOUR ROSE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE
TWO FORTY FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LET ME WALK
THE WOMAN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE TO
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE TWO FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU LINE TO
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO FIVE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI MY
NAME IS CHARLENE TOWER RECORDS
ON ALMOST ADVOCACY FOR CINEMA
COUNTY I OPPOSE. ALL RIGHT NEED
MATAMATA READER IF WE IF WE
COULD GO THROUGH THE ENTIRE
SUPPORT LISTED THEM WILL TURN
OPPOSITION HERE JUST A MOMENT
SO. IS A ARE THERE ANY ONE. SIR
ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE WHOSE-
IN SUPPORT. LINE TWO HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TEARS DISABILITY RIGHT
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB.
EIGHT SIX ZERO SIX ONE ZERO
THAT IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHT SIX ZERO. IN LINE TO
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
ONE OF THE REPUBLIC OF A WITH
YOUR LINE OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT THE- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND LINE TWO
FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
KIANA ALTAMONT FIRE QUALITY
MANAGER WITH CALIFORNIA COMING
BECAUSE WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND ONE
ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH.
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND ONE TO
SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE TWO SEVEN
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
KATHLEEN AROSE CO AND I AM A
RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA AND I AM
NOT- I'D SAY NAY TO A. B. EIGHT
YEAH. SUPPORT OF MAN ONE MOMENT.
THANK YOU IN LINE TO FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU MA'AM OKAY
THANK I AM A GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ôNG AND I'M WITH LONG
INTERVENE POLITICS AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
SIXTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN
LINE TO SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS EMILY I'M WITH BAY
RISING AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHT SIXTY. WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE. RIGHT THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WILL GIVE IT A FEW
MORE SECONDS FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT AND THEN BE BEFORE WE
TAKE THE OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD ANNOUNCE AGAIN I KNOW
THAT LEAST TO CALLERS WHO WERE
IN OPPOSITION WE'RE ON THE FOUR
LINE IF THEY WOULD LIKE THEY
CAN CALL BACK ON THE OPPOSITION
LINE. SO RIGHT ARM I DON'T KNOW
IF THERE'S A LEAD OPPONENTS
WHO'S WHO IS GOING TO TESTIFY
IT. REQUIRES FROM. I'M SORRY GO
AHEAD SAY. REPLY HI YEAH.
COLLECTION FROM THE ROOF FLIES
WHY SEIZE MICE HE'S NOT CALLED
IN THE GLOBAL SO YOU HAVE TO
ASK THE MODERATOR IF YOU CAN
FIND HIM THE OTHER ROOM ALL
RIGHT ROUTE YES- MATTER
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN FIND A
MISS RUTH WEISS WHO WILL BE THE
LEAD OPPONENT WILL GIVE MISS Y.
SO THREE MINUTES IS WE GAVE UP
THE PROPONENTS. THANK YOU. WHY
IF YOU ARE ON THE LINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE DIDN'T ZERO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO THEIR OWN NOW. ONE
MOMENT. TWENTY YOU CAN SEE THAT
A LARGE. YEAH IT'S AVAILABLE
THAT IS. AND ONE MORE MOMENT TO
TERM WHERE WAITING TO SEE IF
SHE'S ON THE LINE. I WENT FOR
THE- ALL ARTICLES I DON'T. WHY
PLEASE PRESS ONE TWO ZERO IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE. AS. ONE
MOMENT DETERMINE WERE STILL
CHECKING LINE ALL RIGHT LET'S
LET'S GIVE IT ANOTHER FIFTEEN
SECONDS OR SO AND THEN WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THOSE WHO OPPOSE.
OKAY AT THIS TIME I DO NOT SEE
HER NAME ON ARE ON MY LIST.
ARMEN IF MS WEISS POPS UP
SOMEWHERE AMONG THE OPPONENTS
WILL GO AHEAD AND AFFORD HER
THE THREE MINUTES THAT WE
DISCUSS SO- MATAMATA READER IF
YOU COULD GIVE INSTRUCTIONS
AGAIN TO THOSE WHO OPPOSE ALL
JUST REMIND. EVERYONE THAT- YOU
SHOULD STATE THEIR NAMETHEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
AS SOON AS OPPOSE THIS POINT.
THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT
SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ALL. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AB. EIGHT SIX ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE IN THEIR OWN
NOW. ALL RIGHT NOT A MODERATOR
IMITATION MAY LOOK LIKE WE DO
HAVE ROOM TWICE ON THE LINE ONE
SECOND IS DETERMINED ALL RIGHT.
THIS YC WITH US. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN MA'AM PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FINE. MISS WEISS GO AHEAD. MY
MAMA MAY MAYBE LINE IS ON MUTE.
HI MISS WEISS IF YOU'RE THERE
OF YOU TAKE YOUR PHONE OFF
BUTTE AND WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
PROVIDE YOU THREE MINUTES. ONE
MOMENT ONE MOMENT TO TELL ME WE
ARE HAVING TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES AT THE MOMENT ONCE
AGAIN ALL RIGHT. OKAY A MIDWIFE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE-
THE RESPONSE OF THE SENATOR OF
US AND WE WILL BERMAN AND I DO
APOLOGIZE IF YOU HAVE TAKEN ARE
COMMON IN THE WRONG WAY BUT
CLEARLY WE WERE NOT. INDICATING
THAT- ANYTHING ABOUT EQUALITY
THERE WE WERE SIMPLY TRYING TO
SHOW THAT THERE ARE SOME MAJOR
RISK OF A BLANKET VOTE BY MAIL
POLICY OUT WE HAVE CHAOS AND
UNRELIABILITY IN OUR STATE
VOTER ROLLS ARE DATED AND NOW
FIFTEEN IT'S PROVEN THAT YOU
AND I. TURN THE NUMBERS INTO
YOU THEY'VE BEEN SHARED WITH
SECRETARY OF STATE THEY'VE BEEN
SHARED IN MEDIA RELEASES ON OUR
DATA ARE COMPLETELY ACCURATE
AND VERY CONSERVATIVE AS WELL
TO THE PROBLEM MAY BE GREAT
DEAL LARGER THAN OUR- DATA.
REALLY SHOW. WE BELIEVE THAT
WOULD BE A REAL PROBLEM TO
STAND VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT OUT
TO THE ENTIRE VOTER ROLE WE
HAVE THIRTEEN COUNTIES THAT
HAVE OVER 1100% OF THEIR
ELIGIBLE POPULATION NUMBERS
REGISTERED TO VOTE MEDICAL.
AFFAIRS COUNTY THE LARGEST.
COUNTY THE ENTIRE NATION AND
LARGE THAN FOR TO STAY. AND
THEY HAVE A 114% OF THEIR
ELIGIBLE POPULATION REGISTERED
TO VOTE AND TWENTY SEVEN MORE.
COUNTY HAVE AN UNREALISTIC
VOTER REGISTRATION OF OVER
NINETY PERCENT. SO ALL IN ALL
OUR CONSERVATIVE DATA SHOW THAT
WE HAVE FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
EIGHT THOUSND PEOPLE STILL ON
THE ACTIVE LIST. WHO ARE LIKELY
TO SEE OR HAVE BEEN RELOCATED
TO OTHER STATE AND THEY'VE NOT
BEEN REMOVED TO THE INACTIVE
LIST AND THEY SHOULD NOT BE
FOUND. A BALLOT UNLESS THEY
REQUEST IT THE CALIFORNIA
ALREADY. 75% OF THE POPULAR BUT
VOTING POPULATION. WELL AS- CAN
CERTAIN BE TRUSTED TO KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE A HEALTH ISSUE AND A
HEALTH CONCERN AND ANYTIME
BETWEEN NOW TODAY AND SEVEN
DAYS BEFORE ELECTION DAY WITH A
PHONE CALL THEY CAN REQUEST
THAT VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT AND
REMAIN SAFELY IN THEIR HOMES
AND CAST THE SAFE BLLOT BUT
THAT THE DECISION SHOULD BE UP
TO THEM SINCE THEY ARE THE ONE
WHO HAS HAD NOT OTHERWISE
QUESTION TWO WHERE SHE VOTE BY
BALLOT. IF YOU IF WE SEND TO
EVERYBODY IN THE STATE
REGARDLESS OF REQUEST NOT WE
ARE GOING TO BE SENT OUT A
LARGE NUMBER OF BALLOTS THAT
ARE GOING TO GO TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE NO LONGER THERE SO WHAT
WHAT ASKING ARE PERMANENT VOTE
BY MAIL BALLOT VOTERS I MEAN
RATHER NON PERMANENT BUT MY MOM
BUT VOTERS TO TAKE. HEALTH
PATIENT AND PICK UP ON IT
THAT'S NOT THE QUESTION IT AND
WENT THREE BUT WHAT YOU VOTERS
THE PRO IS SAID THE VOTE THE
LEGIT OWNERS NOT HOT. WELL THEY
LIVED IN. COULD GET INTO THAT
GEN. ACTION RESULT IT WOULD
FLOOD TELL. WITH OF BALLOTS IN
DA THE PEOPLE WHO ARE NOW
LONGER THERE. AND THE WE THERE
ARE GOING. BE FOR OPPORTUNITY
AND FRAUD. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
MENTION THAT THE- OF THE PERIOD
AND TO TWENTY. FOR RECEPTION IF
ALSO A CO TO US BECAUSE WE'RE
USED TO MEETING DEADLINES AND
FIGHT IT WE KNOW HOW THE NOW
LESS THAN THEIR A- AND OR HOW
TO NOT MAKE THE BUS. BEGINNING
A MOVIE WELL WE DON'T HAVE AN
GET OUR IN OUR ELECTRIC BILL
CUT OFF WE MEET DEADLINE. AND
PEOPLE EXPECT DEADLINES BECAUSE
CHAU PRESERVATION INCOMPETENT
SURE EVERYONE THAT THE SYSTEM
WILL GENERATE AND CALIFORNIA'S
VERY VERY GENEROUS WITH THEIR
PUTTING DEADLINE ALL. THANK.
AND YOU. WILL THIRTY SECONDS SO
IF YOU GO AHEAD CONCLUDE LOW.
YES OF YOU GO AHEAD I AM
CRITICAL NOW. SO WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO INDICATE THE FACT THAT
YOU DO NEED AN EXTRA- SEVENTEEN
DAYS TO RECEIVE THESE BALLOTS
AND THAT WOULD ALLOW ALL OF
THESE BALLOTS THAT ARE GOING
OUT WITH OUR AGENDA THANK THANK
YOU MISS OR THE OTHER AND
RECEIVE THAT IS TO BE
MANIPULATED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT THANK YOU SO IS
ARE YOU STILL ON FOR JUST ONE
SECOND AND DOING YOUR CLOTHES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN- YOU CAN
RESPOND TO THAT BUT JUST TO TWO
QUESTIONS. RECENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA HAD TO- SPECIAL
ELECTIONS WITH ALL WHERE WHERE
VOTERS ARE PROVIDED ALL THE
VOTERS WHO REGISTER WERE
PROVIDED WITH. MAIL IN BALLOTS-
ONE IT WAS WON BY MR GARCIA THE
OTHER ONE BY SENATOR MELINDA'S.
BOB IF YOU'RE AWARE OF VOTING
IMPROPRIETIES- HAVE THEY BEEN
REPORTED TO THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY- IN EITHER THOSE
ELECTIONS A SUMMER ONE AND
NUMBER TWO IF YOU ARE AWARE AND
YOU THINK THAT THERE WAS
IMPROPRIETIES THE- DO YOU. YOU
DO THOSE. SEVEN ON THOSE. WELL
MY RESPONSE TO THAT. OH DEAR
AND I'M GETTING AN ECHO BACK
HERE. I OF. TESTIFIED TO THE
COMMITTEE BUT FOR THAT USED
IMPROPRIETIES ARE EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TO COME TO LIGHT THEY
ARE THEY HAVE BEEN AND THEY ARE
IN DIFFICULT THERE'S NO WAY TO
QUANTIFY WHAT WILL BE HAPPENING
BUT NOT BUT WHEN YOU ARE
MAILING BALLOTS PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN INACTIVE FOR WELL BEING
TWENTY YEARS OR LONGER AND
THEY'RE STILL ON THE VOTER
ROLLS YOU IN. HI LEVY THAT
BALLOT OUT THERE CAN BE NO.
ANYWAY BE NO WAY OF KNOWING
THAT AND- IN TERMS OF THE TWO
ELECTIONS RECENTLY HELD WOULD
YOU SUGGEST THAT WE RE DO THOSE
ELECTIONS. WELL OF COURSE NOT
AGAIN AS YOU HEY WE DO NOT HAVE
THE DATA APPROVED HOW MANY
BALLOTS THEY ARE MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN. FILED INCORRECTLY. I'M
NOT LOOKING AT PAST ELECTIONS
I'M LOOKING AT PROTECTING YOU
SELECT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTERVENE THERE
FOR JUST A SECOND THANKS THANK
YOU MISS WISE. ALL RIGHT- LET'S
NOT TURN TO OPPONENTS WHO I
DON'T SEE ANY OPPONENTS HERE IN
IN ROOM FORTY TWO THREE IS
THERE ARE- MAKE. IF IT IS.
EMPTY A CAN BE I WILL NOW TURN
TO THE PHONE SO MADAME
MODERATOR IF YOU WERE PROVIDE
ONE MORE TIME TO THOSE WHO ARE
OPPONENTS OF IT AB EIGHT SIXTY
SO THAT THEY CAN MAKE
THEMSELVES KNOWN THEY SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
WHICH IS. SUPPOSED AT THIS
POINT. THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEA IN OPPOSITION OF-A. B. SIX ZERO. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF A. B.
EIGHT SIX ZERO. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THERE ARE NOW. ONE MOMENT
CHAIRMAN. LINE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TO THIRTY ONE. ONE MOMENT.
THANK YOU. LINE SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE MOMENT
DETERMINE. HELLO. HELLO ARE YOU.
THEREFORE I AM ADD A FRAMEWORK-
RESIDENT NO COUNTY AND I'M
HEARING ECHO POLITICIAN I'M NOT
CLEAR I AM OPPOSED EIGHT EIGHT
IT'S HAVING ACT BUT- THE VOTER
ROLLS. WHEN OUT HOLDING ON AND
I WAS BY THE AND A MODERATOR IF
WE COULD GO ON THE CALLER.
RAINY THE BOTTLE THE COUNTY A
LOT. BUT TO GO NEXT CALL TO
THEM FOR NOT CALLING THEM I
FIND IT DIFFICULT RESPONSE WILL
KEEP. YOU ARE I THIS BILL IT
THANK YOU MADAM WATER THAT LETS
LET'S STOP NOW BECAUSE WE'VE
QUITE A OF IN THE SO WE NEED TO
GET THIS ORGANIZED HERE RIGHT
OFF THE BAT. SO IF YOU'RE ON
THE PHONE AND CLEANED YOU WISH
TO STATE YOUR POSITION. YOU
SHOULD STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND I ASSUME
YOU'RE OPPOSE BECAUSE AND LET
US KNOW THAT- IN MATTER
MODERATOR IT IF WE GO MUCH
BEYOND THAT I DEBTS THAT YOU
DID CUT THEM OFF AND MOVE TO
THE NEXT CALL. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU LET'S GO THE NEXT CALL.
BLIND THIRTY ONE PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME. YOU'RE ROLLING A
REVISION. YES MY NAME IS PENNY
HARRINGTON FROM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND I'M IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY TWO THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS. DALE FIVE ON
ELECTION INTEGRITY WE- A
TRAINER AND- PUBLIC CHANNEL AND
CAMPAIGN INCREASE. I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO HAVING MANY ARE AYE
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR WOULD
GO THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE THANK
YOU AND LINE. BY ONE FOR THE
LINE UNTIL BEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
OR SHARE. YEAH I'M ARE LONG
TIME FIFTY YEAR RESIDENT OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I THINK THE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LIVE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
LINE ONE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JAMES ERA. I'M A CITIZEN OF
CALIFORNIA PRESIDING UNVEILED I
OPPOSE AB EIGHT SIXTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND LINE
ONE TWENTY FIVE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD MY NAME IS
CELIS NAME IT FROM ARCADIA
CALIFORNIA NINE INCH STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO AB EIGHT SIXTY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND LINE
EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE EIGHTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO WE
CAN HEAR YOU THERE. MY NAME IS
CHARLES GONG. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NINE NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS ROYCE WHITE GOOD-
RESIDENT UNION CITY CALIFORNIA
I STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND LINE TO TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY I'M SORRY MY NAME IS
DAVID SECTOR I AM A RESIDENT OF
THE INTER COUNTY CALIFORNIA I
SPEAK AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN AND
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
YOU KNOW. MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND LINE
FIFTY THREE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
JESSICA BRICKER TWENTY YEAR
SIERRA CLUB MEMBER OPPOSED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND ONE
EIGHTY OUR LINE IS OPEN AND.
ONCE AGAIN LINE ONE EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS CAROL WILSON I'M
A MEMBER AT THE KENNEDY CENTER
COMMITTEE AND I. OPPOSE BILL AB
EIGHT SIXTY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND LINE ONE EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M WAY INFO FOR ALL
PASSED MAYOR OF BILL PARK. I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO IT AB EIGHT
SIXTY AND THANK YOU FOR GETTING
GIVING US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN
LINE ONE TWENTY EIGHT. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JERRY BROWN AMEND RESIDENT A
LOS ANGELES COUNTY STRONGLY
OPPOSED AB EIGHT SIX L. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND ONE SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU IN LINE
TO FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH SO I'M DOCTOR CAN.
OKAY BEAR FROM VENTURA. AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND LINE ONE OLD TO.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN AHEAD. NINE
ONE ZERO NUCLEAR LINE A LITTLE
BIT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
AND ONE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FIFTY SIX THE LINE IS OPEN.
LINE ONE NINETY SEVEN NO ONE IS
BUILDING THE PLAN. HELLO THIS
IS JESSICA LANGE WITH. SAN
MATEO COUNTY AND I OPPOSE IT.
THANK YOU HELLO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND LINE FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
JOHN MORE. SAN DIEGO AND I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO EIGHT SIXTY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND ONE
SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
JEANNIE CHAU COUNTY OF PLASTER
COUNTY ROAD STILL CITIZEN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE MAILING BALLOTS
TO ANY NAME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND ONE ONE FORTY FIVE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BERNADETTE
AND I LIVE IN THE COUNTY OF SAN
MATTEO I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B.
EIGHT SIXTY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND LINE FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH BROUGH I'M
A RESIDENT OF ORANGE COUNTY AND
I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AB
EIGHT SIX ZERO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GO AHEAD. LINE SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN LINE TO
FORTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS TORY
BLACKCURRANT AND THE CONCERN
VOTER IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND LINE
ONE OLD TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE ZERO
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN ONE
MOMENT. ONE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES THIS IS DEANNA
LANE. A RESIDENT STRONGLY
OPPOSED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND LINE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS. ROBERT WHAT ARE YOU.
THERE ARE MORE IN THE BOTTOM
AND AGREE. HELLO AYE OPPOSED
ROOM- HOW MAY BE EIGHT EXTERNAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN. THE STATE ROUTE ONE
MOMENT. LINE FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
MADE. I AM INTERESTED IN. I THE
ONLY A PUBLIC. THANK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT IN TIME IN.
AND MINE TOO TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME
IS CHRIS LESTER I'M PRESIDENT
OF SANTA CLARITA REPUBLICAN
WOMEN IN A POOR AS A FORMER
VOLUNTEER WITH THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT I PERSONALLY
SEEN ON THE LA COUNTY BORDER
THANK YOU MA'AM. GO AHEAD AND
GO TO THE NEXT CALLER. NINE TWO
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AGAIN THAT'S LINE TO NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
HOURS AFTER THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK
YOU. THE LINE MY NUMBER ONE
ZERO THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
KATHLEEN BALD UNION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. THANK YO LINE TO
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A
JURY PARTURITION LOS ANGELES
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU. LINE TWO SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I AM CAME TO KEEP
HALL RESIDENT OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY I'M RETIRED AND VETERANS
I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
EIGHT SIXTY. THANK YOU. BY
NUMBER ONE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS ROBERT
ME I AM A REGISTERED VOTER IN
RANCHO BERNARDO AND I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MERRY DURING SANTA
CLARA COUNTY SAN JOSE CITY OF
SAN JOSE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AND I OPPOSE THAT YOU WON'T
ALLOW US TO GIVE A BRIEF REASON
WHY. AND NINE TO SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS KATHLEEN AROSE CO I'M A
VOLUNTEER FOR ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT CALIFORNIA
AND I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AB
EIGHT SIXTY. THANK YOU. LINE
TWO SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ROBIN BUT REMEMBER CHECK
BOB MARLEY ABOUT. LINE THIRTY
TO KNOW YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS NO WELL HELPING OUR I
AM A CITIZEN OF CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND I AM ADAMANTLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. LINE TWO
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
THAT WOULD COUNTY AND AYE
OPPOSED JUST LOOK WHAT HAPPENED.
THANK YOU. IN LINE THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
JEANNIE MANGUM CITIZEN OF
ORANGE COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. BOB YEAH MINE THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AGAIN
THAT'S LINE THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ON TO LINE
TWO EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I REMEMBER I WAS NEWARK
CALIFORNIA OPPOSED. THANK YOU
EIGHT WHAT I'M GONNA LEAVE. AND
WE'RE JUST GATHERING MORE LINE
NUMBERS IT'D JUST BE A MOMENT
WHILE WE DO THAT. AND NINE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS GLENDALE MYERS I AM
I LIVE IN ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA
AND I'M A SUPPORTER OF ELECTION
INTEGRITY IF YOU PROJECT AM I
OPPOSEDA. B. EIGHT SIX SIX-
THANK YOU. LINE THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME'S LINDA FEEL WORSE
THAN RIVERSIDE COUNTY MEMBER OF%
THE PUBLIC AND LIMóN
ORGANIZATION AND I WAS THE OLD
SERVER IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED A. B.
SIXTY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU MY NUMBER I KNOW THAT
ARE LIKE THEY GOT EVERY NIGHT I
KNOW. I WANT. I. WE NEED ON MAN
MORONS NEXT RIGHT JUST REMINDER
ALL THOSE WHO ARE ON THE PHONE
LINE THAT. WHEN YOU'RE ON YOU
NEED TO TURN OFF YOUR OTHER
DEVICE THAT YOU'RE LISTENING TO
THE HEARING ON. ALL RIGHT MAN
MODERATOR NEXT NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY MOVING ON TO
LINE ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MUTE BUTTON. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES IF I HAD.
OKAY MY NAME IS JACQUELINE LBT
I'M A RESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY IN A VOLUNTEER FOR
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT AND
I AM OPPOSED TO AGE SIXTY.
THANK YOU. NINE TO TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS. MY NAME
IS KAREN WALLY AND I AM A
REGISTERED VOTER IN PLASTER
COUNTY I AM OPPOSED TO AB EIGHT
SIXTY SUPPORT THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROGRAM. THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER TWO THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M KAREN SHOTS I
AM A CITIZEN OF VENTURA COUNTY
AND I AM VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB EIGHT SIXTY AND I ALSO
SUPPORT ELECTION INTEGRITY
PART. THANK YOU MY NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS OUR STRONG MINOR SAN
MATTEO COUNTY REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA VETERANS. THE
IMMENSELY OPPOSED TO ALPHA
BRAVO EIGHT SIXTY THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ELEANOR
BARRY RESIDE IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
I AM HER ONLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
KAREN GROOVY I AM A REGISTERED
VOTER IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND A
SUPPORTER OF THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT I AM
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED TO AB EIGHT
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
TWO NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS DIANE
KARAN H. I'M A REGISTERED VOTER
IN SAN MATEO COUNTY AND I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
EIGHT SIXTEEN THANK YOU. LINE
TWO FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ALL. I GET MINE TWO FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES YES WE CAN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHILE ADAM I'M
FROM KERN COUNTY- WITH THE-
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICAN
ORGANIZATION. AND I HIGHLY
OPPOSE AB EIGHT SIX ZERO THANK
YOU YOU. LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN PLEASE
GO AHEAD OKAY MY NAME IS NANCY
COULD CANYON OF FROM ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND FREMONT JENNISON
RIGHT OPPOSE. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
LINDA SCARE OF BOATERS SAN
DIEGO COUNTY ADAMANTLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU BY NUMBER ONE ZERO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AGAIN
NINE ONE ZERO SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE%
CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD THIS IS
MERRY LAND PELICANS BUT THE TRI
VALLEY REPUBLICANS. AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO A. B. EIGHT
SIXTY. THANK YOU MY NUMBER TWO
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
YEAH HI AND CRAPPIE WORD I
PASTOR A PRETEND ABOUT LIKE
CHURCH AND- GLENDALE CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE. MY
NUMBER TWO ZERO SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD
WE HEAR YOU. MY NAME IS SARAH
JANE I'M WITH AMBER IN INDIANA
COUNTY A BOOK BUT BUT THAT A
FRIEND AND I OPPOSE. THANK YOU
BYE NOW THE FAMILY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS PATRICIA ERIK
I'M WITH THE SEAL BEACH
REPUBLICAN WOMEN FEDERATION AND
I AM COLORS AB EIGHT SIX ZERO
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY
NAME IS ROBERT HOW LONG
PRESIDENT OF MARIPOSA COUNTY
AND I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AN
A. B. EIGHT SIXTY. THANK YOU.
KLEIN NUMBER ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS JOHN
PLUNKETT A- SAN DIEGO COUNTY
VOTER AND I'M IN STRONG
OPPOSITION PARTICULARLY TO THE
SEVENTEEN DAY COURT GRACE
PERIOD. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
TWO SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN CLIENTELE A COUNTY ROAD
STAND AND DOCTOR AGAINST THE LA
COUNTY CLEANUP REGISTER FOR
HAVING TOO MANY VOTERS I'M STOP
ON THE WAY UP TO. THANK YOU
HAVING OUTDATED THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER THREE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PHONE GEN
RESIDENT CLASS YOUR COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. EIGHT
SIXTY. MY NUMBER ONE EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KEITH
MEISSNER REGISTERED VOTER
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPPORTER OF
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT AYE
OPPOSED AB EIGHT SIXTY THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER TWO FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS MARIE CHRIS AND I REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
REPUBLICAN WOMEN FOR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND I AM
EXTREMELY OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE NINE NUMBER THREE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS PATRICIA GRAY
FROM LIVERMORE CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB EIGHT SIXTY
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER THREE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS JURY BENSON I'M
A FIFTY YEAR RESIDENT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND MY WIFE
AND I BOTH OPPOSED THIS
DECEPTIVE BILL. THANK YOU BYE
NUMBER STICK YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES THE STEVEN IN SOME DETAIL
COUNTY LIFELONG DEMOCRAT AND
SUPPORTER OF ONE PERSON ONE
VOTE BUT DON'T SUPPORT A. B.
SIXTEEN THAT'S NOT TRUE. MY
NUMBER SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS MARCIA HAWKINS
I'M A REGISTERED VOTER IN
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. BY NUMBER SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
SOLIS BRANCH COUNTY- POLL
WORKER AND I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. THE LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS SHERRY THE FLOW
OF THE GAME A RESIDENT OF SAN
MATTEO COUNTY AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED AND GLAD THERE'S SO
MANY PEOPLE SPEAKING OUT. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE ZERO NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS PAT WHY IT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SANTA CLARITA. THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AGAIN THAT FLY
NUMBER ONE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY MOVING ON TO
LINE NUMBER TWO TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT NINE EIGHT
IF YOU'RE LOOKING DOLLAR US
THEY DID THEN AND MY LOVE I FOR
ONE UP BECAUSE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MY NAMETWO SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME'S
WALL THIS ENOUGH CONTRACOSTA
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS SUSAN OF A
LIFELONG CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
AND I HAVE BEEN I DON'T WANT TO
HEAR WITH THE INTEGRITY PROJECT
BEGAN VOLUNTEER AND TRAINER AND
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED TO WITH
ALL THE THINGS I'VE SEEN. I
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS TRICIA
CARILLO- FROM VALENCIA
CALIFORNIA AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO AB EIGHT SIXTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MY NUMBER TWO
EIGHT SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OKAY.
MY NAME IS FOR ITS FONG COLON I
WAS AN INSPECTOR FOR THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ELECTIONS THAT THE
ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER FOLDERS
I'M AGAINST THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LEADING MY RD TWELVE
DIFFERENT THIS GOAL I STRONGLY
OPPOSED AID BEING. EIGHT EIGHT
ZERO THANK YOU. BY NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AGAIN THAT LINE THREE
THREE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALRIGHT MOVING ON TO LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS MIKE ONE I'M FROM
BOTH LOCAL CALIFORNIA. AND I
OPPOSE LOOKS BILL. THANK YOU.
AND LINE AT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS REALLY A HOUSE
I'M A BOARD MEMBER OF
DISTILLING COME VALLEY
ASSOCIATION OF REPUBLICAN WOMEN
WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK
YOU. LINE NUMBER NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS NON FAT FINGER A LIFELONG
RESIDENT OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CURRENT RESIDENT OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB EIGHT SIXTY
AND IT SEEMS WE OUT NUMBER THE
SUPPORTERS SIGNIFICANTLY. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS PAT AND I'M FROM WHAT THE
DUNK NOT CALIFORNIA I'M A
RESIDENT AND A STRONGLY OPPOSE
IF PEOPLE CAN I HAD TAKEN PART.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AGAIN THAT'S NINE ONE SIX ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MOVING ON TO
LINE TWO ZERO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SB ROSENWALD I AM A
RESIDENT OF THE LA COUNTY FOR
FORTY YEARS AND I POSTED ALL.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER TWO THIRTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO THIRTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YES WOULD YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS THE KEY AND I'M
WITH INMORE MOLD A CALIFORNIA
AND I ALL. THEY YOU. MY NUMBER
THREE SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH MY NAME IS HOMER
HAWKINS AND I'M A REGISTERED
VOTER ORANGE COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
IT'S GONNA BE A MOMENT WHERE
STILL PROVIDING LINE NUMBERS
FOR A FEW MORE. IF YOU ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE BEEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. OKAY. THIRTY ONE MAR
MOUNT. OKAY.
MADAME MODERATOR
ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WHEN GOVERNOR WOMAN MEMBERS WHO
HAVE VERY GOOD FOR. HOW MANY
THIRTY EIGHT. YEAH. OKAY GOING
TO THE LINE OF. TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A
MOMENT PLEASE. AND WE DO HAVE
OTHERS QUEUING UP IT'S JUST
COULD BE A MOMENT. OKAY LINE
NUMBER TWO FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NAME IS IN BETTER HOW
RESIDENTS SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND
SUPPORTER OF THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT AND I OPPOSE
AB EIGHT SIXTY. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE SIX ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AGAIN THAT'S ONE SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MOVING ON TO
LINE ONE NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN HI MY NAME IS
THERESA NELSON I'M A RESIDENT
OF CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND A
SUPPORTER OF. THE ELECTION
COMMITTEE I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED
AB EIGHT SIXTY THANK YOU. AND
MY NUMBER TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AGAIN THAT'S
LYING TO SEVENTY SEVEN. MOVING
ON TO LINE THREE ZERO FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AGAIN THAT'S
MINUS THREE ZERO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOR MOVING ON TO LINE
THREE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ARE YOU MY NAME IS CAROLYN
MAY SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CONCERNED CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO- CHANGING THE
ELECTION RULES FOR ON SATURDAY
ACCESS TO BALLOTS WHICH MAY BE
SIXTY WILL DO. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER THREE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
SERRA HELP AND I'M A REGISTERED
VOTER IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB EIGHT
SIXTY. THANK YOU. NUMBER THREE
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
ACCIDENTALLY CAME IN LATE IN
THE YEAR IN THE QUEUE- WHEN YOU
WERE VOTING FOR TO GO FOR THE
BILL AB SIX EIGHT SIXTY I'M
CHANGING THAT I'M ACTUALLY A
POST. STRONGLY AB EIGHT SIXTY
MY NAME IS REBECCA SCHWARTZ.
WOULD RIVERSIDE COUNTY THANK
YOU. BY NUMBER THREE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS LINDA CHRYSLER I'M A
REGISTERED VOTER IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
EIGHT SIXTY. THANK YOU. FIND A
LINE A THREE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THEY ALL VOTER
IAN CAN YOU GO COUNTY I'VE
CODES. THANK YOU. LINE THREE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AGAIN
THAT'S LINE THREE THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY MOVING ON TO
LINE THREE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BY CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN. BRYAN DUNCAN FROM
ARCADIA CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THIS BILL
THANK YOU. RIGHT. NINE THREE
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
I'M ROSE ONE TERM ALL THE
PRESIDENT OF THE SOUTH BAY
REPUBLICAN FEDERATION AND LAST
YEAR WE DID A TREMENDOUS
FIGHTING AND VOTER FRAUD AND
FELLOW LETTERS I AM. THE NEXT
TO AB. EIGHT MY NUMBER THREE
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS THE BRAIN WITH SOME
CLOWNING ELDER ABUSE FIVE.
CLOSE THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS DARLA STEVENS I'M
A RESIDENT OF SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
EIGHT SIXTY. THANK YOU. LINE
THREE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AGAIN THAT'S LINE THREE
SIX EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BERMAN WORK FOR THE- MOVING ON
TO LINE THREE SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NATALIE MERIT
KERN COUNTY OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT
ZERO. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
THREE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M JENNIFER JOHNSON FROM
KERN COUNTY AND I OPPOSE AB
EIGHT SIXTY. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER THREE TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS MARILYN
GALLEY AND FROM MONTEREY COUNTY
OF A REGISTERED VOTER AND AYE
OPPOSED EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER THREE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO YES PLEASE AND I HAD. HI
MY NAME IS MELANIE MARKET. AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSES FELL. THANK
YOU. LINE NUMBER THREE SEVEN
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THANK YOU FOR TAKING MY CALL
THIS IS ELLEN IS CONNIE- FROM
FREMONT CALIFORNIA I LIVE IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB EIGHT SIX ZERO THANK
YOU. YOU MY NUMBER TWO FORTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY
NAME IS CAROLYN GAIL I'M FROM
VENTURA COUNTY AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES JUDY VAN HORN
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I LIVE IN LA
COUNTY ARE I AM A REGISTERED
VOTER. PUBLIC AND LIMóN AMWAY
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB EIGHT SIX
ZERO. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DEBORAH COSTS SAID A CONCERNED
CITIZEN IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI JEANNIE
ATKINS SANTA CLARITA CALIFORNIA
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY I OPPOSE
AB EIGHT SIX ZERO. THANK YOU. I
NUMBER ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
FUTURE- RESIDENT OF ROSEVILLE I
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO A BE A
SIXTY THANK YOU. MY NUMBER TWO
ZERO TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. ALBERTA BRIERLEY SANTA
CLARA COUNTY I STRONGLY
APPROACH OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER TWO
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YES WE
CAN. THANK YOU THIS IS CAROLYN
CENTER YOLO COUNTY LONG TIME
ELECTION OBSERVER AND POLL
WATCHER BASED ON MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE I STRONGLY OPPOSE
YOU'D MOVE ONLY BE CALL YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES THIS IS MICHELLE A
BENITEZ I'M A REGISTERED VOTER
IN THE LA COUNTY UNINCORPORATED
AREA OF LAKE HUGHES I HAVE TWO
JOBS. AND I VOLUNTEER BUT THREE
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS AN
EXTREMELY OPPOSE AB EIGHT SIXTY
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BUT SHALL RESIDENT OF SAN
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA IN A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE THAT
THAT THE BILL AB. HI MY NUMBER
THREE ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS GLORIA
NANCY T. NOW ON AYE OPPOSED AB
EIGHT SIXTY I'M A RESIDENT OF
VENTURA COUNTY. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER THREE ZERO THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS BETTY
ROBINSON ARM WITH WE THE PEOPLE
RISING AND ORANGE REPUBLICAN
WOMEN FEDERATED AND- YOU MAY I
HARDLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. I NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS LEAH DAY- I AM
CAN DIEGO COUNTY AND I. EIGHTY
EIGHT SIX THANK YOU. NUMBER
THREE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS TOM SUITOR.
REGISTERED VOTER LOCKER
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I AM
OPPOSED AB EIGHT SIX ZERO.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER THREE FOUR
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MANY
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN ANOTHER
DISTRIBUTOR OF LOS ANGELES AND
I STRONGLY. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER THREE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
GEORGE YOU'RE RIGHT AND I AM
WITH THE SOLANO COUNTY
REPUBLICAN CENTRAL COMMITTEE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
SPELL. THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
THREE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS TRUE FOR US BUT
BUT I'M A FAN A CLEAR COUNTY
REGISTERED VOTERS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I NUMBER
THREE SIXTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS LAURIE AND
I'M IN SAN MATEO COUNTY
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB EIGHT SIXTY. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER THREE EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS ROLE
RODRIGUEZ JUNIOR AND I'M THE
CALIFORNIA COORDINATOR FOR
AMERICA FIRST LATINOS. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT SIXTY THANK YOU THANK. MY
NUMBER THREE NINETY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
TERRY LOVELL I AM A VOTER IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT
SIXTY. THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE ONE OTHER TO OTHERS
QUEUING UP AT TIME. IT JUST BE
A MOMENT. AND MY NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS RHONDA SCOTT HANNAH
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO A. B. EIGHT
SIXTY. I JUST WANT TO ASK IT IS
ALRIGHT MY NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AGAIN
THAT'S LINE THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M NOT
SEEING ANY INDICATION OF THE
NUMBER HERE LET ME. YES IT IS
PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY I'M JAMES
A RIDER I PREVAILED IN THE
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE CONTRA
COSTA ELECTION CONTEST
INVOLVING ILLEGAL VOTE BY MAIL
THANK YOU BYE AND RUN THE WHOLE
MATTER MODERATOR GO HEAD MOVE
THE NEXT CALLER. MY NUMBER
THREE. THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
CATHERINE HERBERT HUBER THURMAN
TAIL REGISTERED VOTERS AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB EIGHT SIXTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BY NUMBER
THREE EIGHT SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN THREE EIGHTY SIX. MY NAME
IS CHRISTINE MAN I AM FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER THREE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS MERRY
STILL SELL. MARY LOOKS LIKE SHE
HAS DROPPED OUT OF THE QUEUE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO GET BACK IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN
ZERO WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE LINE
OF THREE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AGAIN THAT FLY NUMBER
THREE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MOVING ON TO MY NUMBER
THREE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AGAIN NINE THREE SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN PLEASE GO
AHEAD OKAY. MY NAME IS ALKA
MITCHELL I'M A REGISTERED VOTER
THANK YOU GO COUNTY AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO A. B. EIGHT
SIX. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES I AM MARK DOERING SANTA
CLARA COUNTY REGISTERED VOTER
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS SUSAN KENNEDY SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE AB SIXTY.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER THREE
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
MEAN YES WE CAN. MY NAME IS
MICHELLE HAD TURNED FROM A
REGISTERED VOTER IN KERN COUNTY
OR WORK IN CHILD DEVELOPMENT. I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL FOR
AB EIGHT EXCEL I WANT THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER THREE NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS LINDA
VISOR I'M IN LA COUNTY
REGISTERED VOTER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB EIGHT ZERO. THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER THREE NINETY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
ELAINE BOY I'M A REGISTERED
VOTER IN LA COUNTY AND I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER THREE NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
BEVERLY SADLER ORANGE COUNTY
VOTER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY. YOU. MY
NUMBER FOR YOUR A TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AGAIN THAT BLIND FOUR
ZERO TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS FRANCIS AND I'M IN SAN
MATEO COUNTY AND I OPPOSE AB
EIGHT SIX ZERO. THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER FOUR ZERO SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME GLORIA THE PARENTS- I'M
A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
CALLED. WHEN ALLIANCE THAT
BROUGHT YOUR ORGANIZATION AND I
AM STRONGLY SUPPORTING AB EIGHT
SIX ZERO. RT THANK YOU MADAM
BUT A MODERATE ANYONE ELSE IN A
POLL OPPOSITION. IT LOOKS LIKE
WE HAVE ONE MORE IN OPPOSITION
IT'LL JUST BE A MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THE LINE NUMBER. A LIVE
LOOK LIKE WE HAD THREE MORE
LET'S GO TO LINE NUMBER. TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO YES THE HI HAT HI THIS IS
RHONDA SCOTT ALAMEDA COUNTY
REGISTERED VOTER AND I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED. MY NUMBER
THREE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AGAIN THAT'S LINE THREE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MOVING ON TO LINE THREE SEVENTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
FINING NIKE CALL A RESIDENT
VOTER IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED TO A. B.
EIGHT SIXTY THANK YOU. YOU MY
NUMBER FOUR ZERO NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS ALAN
BERGMAN I'M A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB EIGHT SIXTY. THANK YOU. BY
NUMBER THREE NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS
DONALD HAMBURGER LOSS ANGELES.
COUNTY FROM THE OPPOSE A BT
EIGHT SIXTY. THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER FOUR ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MARTY
CARTMELL I AM A THIRD
GENERATION CALIFORNIANS AND
HOMEOWNER AND RESIDENT OF SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I REMEMBER THAT A
UNION CITY SO DISTANT HI I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M SURE A WOLF
I'M A REGISTERED VOTER IN
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB EIGHT SIX
THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM MODERATOR
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP. ALL
RIGHT- LET'S NOW TURN TO THE
DYESS- I KNOW THAT THE SEVERAL
SENATOR. THE CENTER NIELSEN
ASKED EARLIER SIR NIELSEN.
GERMAN COLLEAGUES YEAH I
UNDERSTAND THE INTEREST IN THE
BILL I ACTUALLY EXPECTED A LOT
MORE INTEREST IN HAS BEEN
MANIFESTED HERE TODAY. A
GENERAL OBSERVATION AND I WANT
TO FOCUS ON A ONE PARTICULAR
PROVISION THAT I WILL PROPER
AND AMEND THAT RELATED TO FOR
DECADES I'VE BEEN HERE THAT
THEIR BILL AFTER BILL AFTER
BILL PURPORTEDLY TO ENHANCE
VOTER PARTICIPATION IN OUR
ELECTIONS AND NOBLE GOAL WILL
SEEK. OVER THE DECADES HAVE THE
OR- VOTING PERCENTAGES CHANGE
MUCH HARDLY. THEY HAVE BEEN
THEY FLOW BUT ALL WITHIN A
PRETTY SIMILAR RANGE ON RARE
OCCASIONS BECAUSE CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES THERE'LL BE A LOT
OF INTEREST. BUT THEN WE GO
BACK TO THE MALAISE. AND I JUST
WOULD OBSERVE THAT I THINK THAT
IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE A MUCH
MORE RESOLVED PARK ON OUR
FAMILIES. OUR EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEMS AND JUST SOCIETY. TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO EXERCISE
THEIR FRANCHISE TO VOTE. AGAIN
THERE ARE TIME AND TIME AGAIN
THAT NEW IDEAS. AND NOW HERE IS
A YET ANOTHER ONE. WILL IT MAKE
A CONCLUSIVE DIFFERENCE I DON'T
KNOW. BUT I DO HAVE A GREAT
RESERVATIONS ABOUT ALL THE
BALLOT FLOATING OUT THERE NOW.
TOWARDS THE END IN SECTION TWO
YOU WOULD BEGIN ON. LINE NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE. IT TALKS JUST TO
SUMMARIZE FROM THAT SECTION
THREE THOUSAND POINT FIVE
EIGHTY HAND NOT WITHSTANDING OF
THE LAW. STATE WIDE THE GENERAL
THAT WILL BE HELD AT THE MEMBER
THIRD. TWENTY TWENTY THE COUNTY
ELECTION OFFICIAL SHALL NO
LATER THAN TWENTY NINE DAYS
BEFORE THE DAY OF THE ELECTION.
TO EVERY REGISTERED VOTER. AND
THEN I WOULD WANT TO INSERT
AFTER EVERY REGISTERED VOTER
ONLINE THIRTY FIVE THE WORDS
EXCEPT. IN ACTIVE VOTERS IN THE
GLOBAL IT WOULD GO ON IN THE
COUNTY. AND THEN THE COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL FEEL HAVE
FIVE DAYS THE POINT THERE IS.
IN ACTIVE VOTERS WE KNOW THERE
ARE A LOT OF THEM. THE LA
COUNTY WAS ORDERED TO I CAN'T
THINK FORGET ABOUT ONE POINT.
AND A HALF MILLION VOTERS FROM
THE ROLLS EVERY YEAR WE HAVE
THE PROLIFERATION. AND THE
REGISTRARS AND EVEN THE
SECRETARY STATE I ALWAYS SAY WE
JUST DON'T HAVE THE PEOPLE
POWER. THE PERSIAN KEEP THESE
VOTING ROLLS UP TO DATE. AND
SOME OF THE DECEASED A BEEN ON
FOR YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS.
THAT WOULD BE IT IS WE TAKE
STEPS FORWARD THEN IF YOU
CONSIDER THIS FORWARD I DO NOT
BUT THAT WE DO I WOULD THEN ASK
THEN MANAGEMENT CHAIRMAN IF
THAT THE AS A FORMAL. FORMALLY
SUBMITTED. AMENDMENT TO BE
ADOPTED INTO THE BILL. OF THANK
YOU CENTER NIELSEN OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN CARE TO RESPOND
SURE IN AT ONE THING THE
SENDER- FOR HIS COMMENTS AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT MASK THE
ARE GOING ON- IF YOU CAN SEND
ME A LINK I WANT ONE MYSELF
DONE TO THE CONCERNED ABOUT
ADDING THAT ABOUT ADDING
SPECIFICALLY STATING IN ACTIVE
VOTERS ARE NOT TO AN ACTIVE
VOTERS IN THAT SECTION OF THE
BILL IS THAT. ADDING THAT
LANGUAGE. EVEN IMPLICATION THAT
INACTIVE VOTERS ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE GETTING BALLOTS. FOR VOTERS
CHOICE ACT MAIL BALLOT
ELECTIONS. AND MAILED OUT
PRECINCTS- NOW. NOBODY HAS EVER
INTERPRETED CALIFORNIA LAW TO
IMPLY THAT THE THAT THE
REGION'S THAT FOLLOW VOTERS
CHOICE ACT MAIL BALLOT
ELECTIONS IN MAY ABOUT
PRECINCTS SHOULD BE SENDING
THEM TO AN ACTIVE VOTERS BUT IF
WE- SPECIFICALLY STATE THAT
THIS PREVENTION AND THEN ONE TO
CREATE THE IMPLICATION THAT.
INACTIVE VOTERS SHOULD GET
BALLOTS IN THOSE OTHER
SITUATIONS- AND SO I'M OPEN TO
IT TO YOU KNOW US TALKING AND
TRYING TO GET A BETTER SENSE
AND MAKING SURE THAT- IF
THERE'S A WAY TO DO THIS WITH
OUT. THEM CREATING AN
IMPLICATION WE SHOULD BE
SENDING AN ACTIVE VOTERS
BALLOTS IN OTHER SITUATIONS BUT
NOBODY HAS EVER. THAT IS ACTIVE
VOTER TO GET BALLOTS YOU READ.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY SIX SECTION A
SUBSECTION TWO OF THE ELECTIONS
QUOTA CLEARLY SAYS THAT IN
ACTIVE VOTER REGISTRATION
STATUS MEANS THAT YOU DO NOT
RECEIVE ELECTION MATERIAL SO I
THINK THIS IS THE ALL IN ALL
DUE RESPECT A BIT OF A RED
HERRING- I DON'T ACTUALLY THINK
THIS IS. AN ISSUE- I DON'T WANT
TO CREATE AN ISSUE BY CREATE A
BIKE BY CORRECTING A NON ISSUE-
BUT I NEED A WILL LOOK INTO
THIS FURTHER. TO SEE IF THERE
WAYS TO. YEAH FURTHER CLARIFY
THE EXISTING LAW THAT IS ALWAYS
BEEN INTERPRETED TO READ THAT
IN ACTIVE VOTERS DO NOT RECEIVE
ELECTION MATERIALS INCLUDING-BALLOTS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN I ASSUME BY YOUR
COMMENTS HERE YOU'RE NOT
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT.
CORRECT SENATE HURTS. YOU KNOW
I WON- A DOVE TAIL A BIT ON
CENTER NIELSEN'S POINT ABOUT
HOW THE CHALLENGES OVER MANY
YEARS. ON THE BEEN NOTHING LESS
AN EXTRAORDINARY AND THAT WE
REALLY HAVEN'T SEEN SOME
SIGNIFICANT. INCREASE
INTERNALIZED THE CITY COUNCIL
IN THE ONE OF THE COMMITTEES
ARE REPRESENTED IN LOS ANGELES
EIGHT POINT 9% CORPORATE LAW
REQUIRES A QUORUM BASICALLY OF-
ENTITY BEFORE YOU CAN CONDUCT
BUSINESS I. DEEPLY CONCERNS ME
AND I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
THIS ISSUE. IN MY ENTIRE
POLITICAL CAREER IN MANY
DIFFERENT CAPACITIES- AND
TRYING TO DO EVERYTHING HUMANLY
POSSIBLE TO CREATE AN OPEN AND
HONEST ELECTION WITH THE MOST
NUMBER OF PEOPLE PARTICIPATING
SOME COUNTRIES YOU KNOW. MAKE
IT ILLEGAL NOT TO VOTE LINCOLN
THAT DURING THE CIVIL WAR GAVE
EVERYONE OF THE UNION SOLDIERS.
OF FREE RAILROAD PASSED IN
FIFTEEN DAYS LEAVE TO GO VOTE
RIGHT. THERE'S BEEN ALL SORTS
OF THINGS A LOT OF COUNTRIES
YOU GO HOME TO HOME TOWN WHERE
THERE'S REALHOMETOWNS OF
PEOPLE BECAUSE OF THE GUYS A
BIG PLACE WHERE THEY DO THAT
AND GET REALLY HIGH TURNOUT.
WHAT DO WE DO. WE HAVE AN APPLE
IN THIS- FOR YEARS AGO I. WITH
THIRTY DAY REGISTRATION NIGHT
IN CAMPAIGNING SO MANY TIMES
YOU GO TALK TO PEOPLE. WOULD
JUST MOVE THEIR APARTMENT A NO
AND THEY DIDN'T BE REGISTERED
CHANGE THE REGISTRATION SO WE
TRY TO GET SAME DAY
REGISTRATION OR GRAY DAVIS WE
GOT FIFTEEN DAYS. COULD YOU
MOVED UP CHECK DONE. DURING OUR
GORE'S ELECTION WE HAD THE
HANGING CHADS WE HAD MACHINES
THAT HAD REAL PROBLEMS TURNED
OUT WE TOOK A LOOK AT
CALIFORNIA 53% OF OUR MACHINES
WE JUST LIKE FLOORS WITH
HANGING CHADS SO. WE ARE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO PUT IT PUT
ON THE BALLOT AND BUT
INITIATIVE TO TRY TO. DEAL WITH
THAT IT DIDN'T GET OUT
PERFECTLY BUT KEEP. PUSHING AND
PUSHING THE ENVELOPE AND I IN
FACT INTRODUCED THIS VERY BILL
THAT YOU HAVE HERE TODAY. SIX
YEARS AGO WHEN I FIRST CAME
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE. IN FOR
A SERIES OF REASONS WE CHOSE IN
THE SENATE TO MOVE. SENATOR
ALLEN AND I WAS THEN CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE. IN PARTNERSHIP
THROUGH JOINT AUTHORSHIP OF
CENTERS THING THAT IF YOU
EXTENDED TIME FOR TEN DAYS TO
GIVE PEOPLE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
THAT WOULD WORK. SO WHY I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS I WOULD
MOVE THE BILL AND ASKED IF I
COULD BE JOINED ON IN SOME
CAPACITY. IT'S SOME APPROPRIATE
TIME AS A- PRINCIPAL CALL OR
WHATEVER WHAT MANNER YOU DEEM
TO SUPPORT THIS BUT- YOU KNOW I
DO THINK THE CHALLENGING AND
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS IS
THE SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT THING
WE CAN DO. YOU KNOW WHAT OUR
SCHWARZENEGGER BIG RAN FOR
GOVERNOR HENCE THE TURNOUT IS A
MOVIE STAR. WE'RE NOT MOVIE
STAR EPISODE. BUT I JUST THINK
THAT A- WOULD TRYING CONTINUE
FIX TO MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE
PARTICIPATE. IS A GOOD THING
AND THAT'S WHY I SUPPORT THIS.
AND YOU KNOW THERE WERE ISSUES
QUITE FRANKLY WERE THE
REGISTRAR'S IN CERTAIN COUNTIES
DID WANT TO DO THIS BECAUSE IT
WAS TOO EXPENSIVE AND TOO
COMPLICATED AND MY ATTITUDE IS.
WHAT COULD BE MORE PRECIOUS
THAN THE RIGHT TO VOTE SO WITH
THAT AGAIN I MOVE THE BILL AND
THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING IT.
THANK YOU PLEASE ENTER THANK
YOU SO HERTZBERG ANYONE ELSE.
YES STERN. JUST A QUICK COMMON
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY- AND
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I'D ALSO
LIKE TO BE ADDED ON IT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME IF POSSIBLE
AND I JUST. I WISH THAT THIS
CONVERSATION MORE CURRENT IN
STATE LEGISLATURES ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY- SO. FEEL SO PRIVILEGED
TO BE SITTING IN A POSITION
WHERE WE HAVE. SUCH PROACTIVE
LEADERSHIP FROM. CHAIRMAN IN
BOTH ELECTIONS COMMITTEES IN
BOTH HOUSES WAS FROM OUR
SECRETARY STATE WHO JUMPED IN.
UNHESITATINGLY AS WELL AS THE
GOVERNOR ON THIS AND- YOU KNOW
I DO THINK THERE'S SOME
EXISTING LEGAL AUTHORITY TO DO
WHAT. SECRETARY'S ALREADY
STARTED TO PURSUE BUT- I SEE
THIS MEASURE IS A CRITICAL
PIECE OF GUARDING AT AFRICAN
REPLIED YOU FOR TAKING ITSELF.
THANK YOU THE SENATE. IF I.
COULD RETURN I'D LIKE TO
REQUEST A ROLL CALL VOTE ON IT
THOUGH JUST TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
WE HAVE OFFERED THE AMENDMENT.
ROLL CALL VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENT. ON THE AMENDMENT NOT
ON THE BILL BUT ON THE
AMENDMENTS AT THIS POINT. ALL
RIGHTY- SO WE ARE MOVING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE NIELSEN
ASKING FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE ALL
RIGHT. MR I'LL MOVE THE MEMBERS.
REGION THAT ALMOST ALL RIGHTS
ARE VOTE AGAINST IT BUT ON THE
MOVE FOR. ARE ALL RIGHT IN-
MISTER SECTORS SUMA TAKES A
MAJORITY OF THE COMMITTEE TO GO
AHEAD ALL RIGHT. THIS SECTOR
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. TO BE ON
SENATOR NIELSEN'S AMENDMENT
NUMBER CALL ON BURKE NO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
NO LEYVA NOW LEYVA KNOWN STERN
NOW STERN NO WRITING CENTER THE
AMENDMENT FAILS ALL RIGHT AND
THEY ALSO NIELSEN IF I MAY JUST
TO CLOSE IN AND ALL DIFFERENCE
TO MY COLLEAGUES INTO THE
AUTHOR. AND NO WAY TO OWN AND
TO ANYONE ON THIS BUT IT'S A
TROUBLING THING TO ME OVER SO
MANY YEARS AND SO MUCH
DIFFICULTY THAT WE'VE HAD
ELICITING THE RESPONSE FROM THE
CITIZENS TO EXERCISE THE RIGHT
TO VOTE. IN A REALLY DISTURBS
ME THAT WE TO SO VIGOROUSLY
PURSUE. MAIL VOTING. WHAT IS
THE BEST DISCIPLINE FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY AS TO WHETHER
SOMEONE IS REGISTERED TO VOTE A
LEGAL CITIZEN TO VOTE. THE
LOCAL POLLING PLACE WHO ARE
MANNED BY YOUR NEIGHBORS.
THAT'S A GREAT DISCIPLINE BUT
WE DON'T HAVE MUCH OF THAT
ANYMORE IT'S WANING IN FACT
MANY ARE SAYING WE SHOULD NOT
HAVE THESE LOCAL PLACES%
ANYMORE. IT'S A PROBLEM FOR
SOCIETY AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT
WE SHOULD REALLY PAY ATTENTION
TO THAT IN OUR HEARTS AND SOULS
EACH OF US INDIVIDUALLY. ABOUT
IN THE ENCOMPASSING OTHER
PEOPLE TO VOTE. THANK YOU
pINDULGENCE THANK YOU- MISTER
VICE CHAIR. ALL RIGHT- THANK
YOU BEFORE YOU CLOSE JUST JUST
COUPLE CONCLUDING COMMENTS I DO
FIND IT INTERESTING AND IRONIC
THAT THIS IS SOMEHOW BEEN
POSTURED AS A PARTISAN ISSUE
FROM THE VERY TOP- IT IS
EVIDENCED BY THE FOLKS WHO
CALLED IN TODAY ON THE PHONE- I
JUST JUDGE MY OWN HOME COUNTY
THAT THE GROUP THE
PROLIFERATION OF. MAIL IN
BALLOTS THE BETTER REPUBLICANS
DO IT JUST ILLUSTRATE THE LAST
TWO ELECTIONS- HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE BUT FOR THE
MAIL IN BALLOTS- ORANGE COUNTY
THAT- FIVE OF THE SIX CURRENT
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WHO ARE
DEMOCRATS WOULD WOULD NOT OF
ONE BECAUSE REPUBLICANS DID SO
MUCH BETTER BALLOT BALLOTS.
THERE IS NO EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE
THAT SUPPORTS. THE PROPOSITION
SOMEHOW MARYLAND BALLOTS A
BENEFIT ONE PARTY OVER THE
OTHER I WOULD ARGUE THAT IN
FACT IN IN OUR KELLY THEY WILL
BENEFIT REPUBLICANS OVER
DEMOCRATS BUT BE THAT AS IT MAY.
I ALSO HIM ALWAYS FASCINATED BY
VOTING HAVING SPENT TIME IN
OTHER COUNTRIES WITNESS FOR
EXAMPLE IN AFGHANISTAN PEOPLE
WHO LITERALLY GIVE THEIR LIVES
TO VOTE WAIT FOR SOMETIMES
DAYS. TO BE ABLE TO VOTE AND-
AGAIN REST THEIR LIVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES LIVES TO DO SO
THE THAT WE HAVE SO MANY
CHALLENGES HERE IN UNITED
STATES MAKING SURE THAT WE- IN
FRANCHISE AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE. OF HAVING SAID THAT
THOUGH THE THIS IS A- MEASURE
THAT THE DOES SO PARTICULARLY
IN LIGHT OF THE CURRENT. CODE
NINETEEN CRISIS FACING
CALIFORNIANS SO- I APPLAUD YOUR
LEADERSHIP I APPLAUD YOUR
EFFORTS AND COURAGE
CALIFORNIANS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS. LEGITIMATE PROCESS OF
VOTE. BY MAIL- WE'RE GOING TO
SEE I THINK OTHER BILLS TO
PROVIDE FOR VOTING- IN PERSON
VOTING WILL BE AN OPPORTUNITY I
BELIEVE FOR EVERY PERSON
CALIFORNIA TO VOTE IN PERSON IF
THEY SHOULD TEACH SO CHOOSE.
BUT I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE
ACTUALLY FLATTEN THE CURB BUT
IF YOU WANT TO VOTE IN PERSON
YOU DO SO PRIOR TO ELECTION
DAY. SO HAVING SAID THAT. MR
BERMAN OUT OF TURN OVER TO YOU
FOR YOUR CLOTHES THANK YOU-
CHARMER AGAIN- THE- AGREE WITH
A LOT OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE TODAY AND THEN THINK THAT
IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT WE FIND
OPPORTUNITIES TO INCREASE- THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR. CALIFORNIANS
TO VOTE IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT
MORE PEOPLE DON'T VOTE. THIS
BILL IS REALLY ALL ABOUT.
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE CAN
VOTE SAFELY- ANYWAY I THOUGHT
IT WAS GREAT THAT SO MANY
PEOPLE. HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CALL IN- TO THE HEARING TODAY
FROM THE SAFETY OF THEIR OWN
HOME- THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO COME.
TO SACRAMENTO THEY DIDN'T HAVE
TO WAIT IN LINE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE TO STAND NEAR EACH OTHER
THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO RISK THEIR
HEALTH. THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
IS TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH. TO
MAKE THAT OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO EVERY
CALIFORNIA THAT FOR THE
NOVEMBER GENERAL ELECTION. AND
MAKE IT EASY AS POSSIBLE FOR
THEM. TO VOTE FROM HOME I DO
WANT TO SAY THERE WERE. SOME
ACCUSATIONS THROWN AROUND
AROUND VOTER FRAUD- AND AS WE
ALL KNOW THERE'S BEEN NO- ALL
THE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THERE'S
BEEN NO. SYSTEMIC VOTER FRAUD.
IN CALIFORNIA OR IN AMERICA
THIS PRESIDENT ACTUALLY SET UP.
AND BROUGHT THE FULL FORCE AND
WEIGHT. OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BEHIND A VOTER FRAUD
COMMISSION. THAT DISSOLVE THE
BEFORE THEY FOUND ANY VOTER
FRAUD AND DON'T YOU THINK THAT
IF THEY HAD FOUND VOTER FRAUD
IN CALIFORNIA. VOTER FRAUD
EXISTED IN CALIFORNIA THEY
WOULD HAVE FOUND IT. AND THEY
WERE BROADCASTED FROM VERY
RADIO STATION OR TWITTER
PROFILE THEY COULD POSSIBLY DO
IT FROM- SO I REALLY. I THINK
IT'S SAD. THAT INDIVIDUALS AND
GROUPS. TRY TO DELEGITIMIZE ARE%
ALLEGE THE ELECTORAL SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA BY CONSTANTLY
THROWING AROUND ACCUSATIONS OF
VOTER FRAUD- AND WOULD
DISCOURAGE THEM FROM DOING SO
WITHOUT ANY. FACTS BUT
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE TODAY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT IS THERE MOTION
THAT'S RIGHT CENTERS FOR GOOD
MOVE IT UP THE SECTOR TO CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG
AYE NUMBER HI NIELSEN. THE
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG AYE LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE STERN HI STERN HI BUT FORTY
ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
BILL IS OUT TO US AND
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
THANK YOU HEARING IS ABOUT.